au fait c'est l'endroit c'est une place
forte bibracte ou vercingétorix a uni
les tribus gauloises
avant d'affronter jules césar la
politique est faite de symboles et
arnaud montebourg a bâti le sien une
ascension comme françois mitterrand à
solutré à cheval sur la saône et loire
et la nièvre fief politique sur un grand
site archéologique voulue par françois
mitterrand autre référence au mythe
socialistes et les archives de ce rendez
vous rappelle la tumultueuse trajectoire
d'arnaud montebourg rénovateurs du ps
d'abord militant de la sixième
république et j'ai inscrit nulle il est
temps collectivement de casser ce
système est de donner le sentiment que
la gauche elle préfère le partage du
pouvoir plutôt que l'accumulation
capitalistique de mandat pour
quelques-uns au printemps 2011 c'est le
candidat à la primaire qui monte au
sommet très entouré le député de la
bresse va être le troisième homme de
cette primaire et la gauche du parti se
range derrière lui c'est aussi le
rendez-vous des rénovateurs qui ont fait
bouger beaucoup le parti socialiste et
dont les idées aujourd'hui sont en train
de gagner au sein du parti socialiste
bonjour ça va toujours plus haut en 2012
après l'élection de françois hollande
c'est le ministre du redressement
productif tout juste nommé qui monte au
sommet et qui attire les foules
notre mission est d'abord de sauver tous
les emplois industriels qui peuvent
l'être 2016 encore une autre ambiance
plus de pique nique mais un pupitre plus
de chaussures de marche mais un plan
média chassé du gouvernement arnaud
montebourg s'oppose il lance les bases
de sa candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
tenter de réconcilier et réunifier les
deux france à france qui va bien avec la
france qui va marier en tant qu'on n'a
pas entendu parler comme ça enfin la
retrouver la gorge mais voilà mais le
sommet parfois proche de la chute en
2017 il n'y a plus grand monde autour
d'arnaud montebourg sur les sentiers du
beuvray emmanuel macron vient de gagner
la présidentielle
arnaud montebourg est tout de même venu
soutenir ses amis députés mais le
symbole du beuvray ne sera pas suffisant
ils perdront quelques jours plus tard